can you get all the nutrition you need
from today's food or do you need to be
taking supplements well some people
swear by multivitamins others say they
either aren't effective or actually can
cause some harm
makers of a vitamin pack called 90 for
life say their product provides 90
essential nutrients for life
dr joel wallick has a bachelor of
science in agriculture and a doctorate
in veterinary medicine from the
university of missouri colombia in a
doctorate of naturopathic medicine from
the national college of naturopathic
medicine in portland oregon he was also
a nominee for the nobel prize in
medicine for his stunning discoveries in
the use of trace minerals to prevent
catastrophic diseases in newborns he's
also referred to as doc wallach he
realized that traditional medicine was
very flawed in its focus on treatment
rather than focusing on preventing
disease through proper nutrition this
was something he learned and was
essential in veterinary medicine because
there is no health insurance for animals
striving to provide americans with a new
view of health and healing doc authored
dead doctors don't lie and the book
tells a story of doc wallach's journey
to discovering the importance of proper
nutrition it goes into how degenerative
diseases are linked to specific mineral
and vitamin deficiencies
he's also started a company called
youngevity that provides high quality
nutritional supplements to enrich your
quality of life at healthwaynews.com
he's our guest on the show today he's
here to talk to us about health the
importance of proper nutrition and what
people can do to stay healthy we'll also
talk about the 90 for life product
produced by youngevity in the value
of supplements welcome to the program
doc well thank you gary appreciate your
hospitality i'm happy to be here yeah
great to have you on the program um
let's talk about the book dead doctors
don't lie it's pretty provocative title
um tell us about it
well basically um the average lifespan
of medical doctors according to their
own survey which came out in 1999 is 56
and so why would anybody want to listen
to a group of people whose average
lifespan is 56 to be a hundred
also
this story came out in um
february 5th
and it was a big story it was from the
institute of medicine the journal the
american medical association the centers
for disease control
and they said that um medical doctors
each year there's a yearly figure kill
injured infect 15 million patients in
hospitals in clinics across america
alone can you repeat that statistic one
more time please they kill injured
infect 15 million patients in hospitals
and clinics each year in america alone
medical doctors medical doctors do yes
and so um how many people would fly
commercial airlines if they knew they
killed injured infected 15 million
people how many people go to a fast food
restaurant if they know they killed
injured infected 15 million customers
and so i thought it was
quite interesting since the medical
system has
been able to wiggle themselves into a
protective monopoly that is
self-policing since 1914 following a
report called the flex report
and
they're totally unimpeachable they can
kill with impunity it seems and
they get a walk nobody even gets a
parking ticket
so so
dead doctors don't lie what's really the
basis for the book so you reveal those
those truths yes sir in your book um and
then you go into some other topics well
sure well basically as you pointed out
very very well uh in veterinary medicine
we don't health have health insurance
for animals
and
a farmer is not going to
pay seventy eight thousand dollars
for a hip replacement for a ten thousand
dollar bull
okay and so we had to learn how to
regrow cartilage we had to learn how to
regrow a heart would what a bull has
congestive heart failure we can deal
with that in five days it's a deficiency
of a single vitamin doctors like heart
transplants to make a quarter of a
million dollars when it should cost a
couple bucks
to deal with congestive heart failure
things like um alzheimer's disease i
said in 1993 when the original dead
doctor don't lie audio cassette tape
came out in 1993 that alzheimer's
disease was a physician-caused disease
it actually caused
by deficiencies of nutrients rather than
a genetically transmitted disease as
doctors said
and of course that set off a firestorm
and
really brought us to the level we're
nationally looked at so
in your view you see that
most diseases are essentially
the result of a deficiency of a mineral
or a vitamin
and can be treated by simply taking a
supplement
in most cases in most cases it can
be prevented or reversed with
nutritional supplements that includes
omega-3s amino acids vitamins and
minerals
for instance there's not a single birth
defect that's caused by genetic
problems
although doctors say oh gene all birth
defects are caused by genetic problems
and there's not a single one
you have to appreciate gary that over
the thousands of years that there's been
philosophers and physicians and medical
doctors
there's thousands of failed medical
theories
and the most recent one we're living
through right now is a failed medical
theory that all diseases are caused by
bad genes if they could just build a
good gene take an engineer one replace
the bad gene with a good one everything
being fine there's not a single disease
that's genetically transmitted and so
we're living through kind of the end
of this
time where everybody thought that every
disease was caused by bad genes
it's called epigenetics epigenetics is a
term given to the process by which your
dna and your genes require certain
nutrients to maximize their genetic
potential in other words let's say we
have the
potential to live 200 years which only
would be 45 years because you don't give
your genes the raw materials they need
to get to the 200 year mark
and so that's where we're at
there's not a skull disease that's
caused by
genes it's actually all nutritional
deficiencies
now doc
if somebody
says well i eat a healthy diet
uh
is it necessary for them to take
supplements
absolutely impossible
to have an adequate diet eating healthy
and there's two reasons for that gary
number one at three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street new york city on the bluff
overlooking the construction of the
brooklyn bridge thomas edison pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
generating plant within 10 years every
town every municipality and every city
in the industrialized world converted
from wood is universal fuel into
electricity
well wood was our source
of nutritional minerals for thousands
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of years because the ashes
aren't really ashes their minerals are
left when you burn the wood for fuel you
would throw these minerals aka wood ash
into the garden
the corn and the beans and tomatoes and
sweet potatoes and onions would soak up
those minerals you'd eat them and you
get your meals in that fashion once we
went to electricity nobody replaced
that traditional source of mineral
nutrients
secondly
we began to dam up the big rivers
for two reasons number one people
complained about flooding in the cities
and then secondly um they needed more
electricity because of the demand for
electricity group
well
um when it would flood every year
the flood would leave silt and mud in
the fields which are a source of
minerals from mountains hundreds of
miles away
and the farmers would plow that back in
so the mineral source is renewed into
the fields every year by flooding and
every day at least in the rows near the
farmer's house by throwing the wood
ashes out into the garden
both those sources the traditional
sources of nutritional minerals went
away and here come the medical doctors
don't you dare take vitamins and
minerals you can overdose you know
and so that between the respected person
telling people not to take supplements
our source of nutritional minerals going
away because the wood ash is one of it
because of electricity use
and damming up the rivers so we no
longer got flooding we're in big trouble
so
some people would would argue you know i
supplements are too expensive i already
eat healthy what do you say to people
who feel that supplements are just too
expensive to purchase death is very
expensive gary
disease is very expensive i'll give you
a couple of examples
you look at a preemie
for the three months in the hospital
cost on the average this was just a
cover story in time magazine
um
it cost 280 000 for a premium for three
months on the average someone cost 500
000 but on the average it's 280 thousand
some of them cost 150 000 but on the
average 280 thousand
for 1200 worth of supplements for the
nine months of pregnancy
they'll never be another preemie
which is that simple we've done that in
the animal industry because you can
imagine a farmer
having to put pre-meat calves in an
incubator for three months your
hamburger would cost you 500 a pound
just to pay for the preemie care for
calves
and
um secondly
let's look at things like um very simple
stuff like joint replacements
a hip replacement in america costs 78
deals with one joint doesn't deal with
the other 71 joins the body
our program for supporting and promoting
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons joints if you will
backs
it would cost for a 200 pound man big
fellow like yourself it would cost
say 1500
for three months
hundred dollars and after that two
hundred fifty dollars a month for
maintenance as opposed to seventy eight
thousand dollars
um the thing that's broken america
financially
is
the high cost of ineffective dangerous
medical treatments
okay and so it's much better to use
supplements than it is to do surgery
and of course it's medical doctors who
say
that supplements are dangerous
well in 2007 gearing the fda finally
submitted to the pressure of the
pharmaceutical industry and doctors and
reported the first time for the first
time ever
the um
the reports would be coming in
for
um people saying
i got diarrhea but taking too much
vitamin c i got itchy skin from taking
too much niacin
and i got headaches from taking some of
those herbs that are in energy drinks
my heart really went fast i went to the
emergency room 600 reports
adverse events reports they call them
in 2007 reported in 2008
for herbs bottoms minerals
600 adverse events reports 400 were
in
herbs and 200 environmental minerals
the same year 2007 reported in 2008 it
was just short of 500 000 adverse event
reports for
prescribed pharmaceuticals
500 000
versus
and of course most of the 500 000 were
deaths
none of the nutritional or herbal
adverse events reports or deaths
now those pretty shocking figures when
you look at the
the natural supplement versus the the
big pharma uh
medications over the counter drugs um
so when somebody's going into the store
and they they see the the lines of
vitamins
um
how how do they make an informed choice
is there's so many companies there's so
many so many uh choices out there um
first of all what are before we get into
that specifically what are some of the
the key you have 90 for life is your
program uh but what are some of the
would you say top 10 vitamins that are
that that people really need to focus on
well first of all
you ever heard a cake recipe gary
no i have not
never heard of a cake recipe oh a cake
recipe i'm sorry i thought you mentioned
a name i think you mentioned kate reci
i'm sorry i don't know who that is
oh kill a cake recipe of course let's
say he has 25 ingredients
what if you just take the fur the ten
you like and leave out the other 15.
you're not gonna have a very good cake
right it's gonna be a pancake it's gonna
taste awful or it's gonna be gritty or
it's not gonna be right and so we like
to talk about all the known essential
nutrients okay we're going to assume
you're going to get a smattering of this
and that and but it's not going to be
you can eat a tomato from the same
garden every day but one tomato might
have 10 of the nutrient and the next
tomato has three and so on
and it's not very predictable we're
supposed to be the high end of the
intelligence chain so let's take all 90
essential nutrients 60 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids 3
essential fatty acids so to get the
complete cake recipe you need all 90.
and so i i'm always reluctant to pick
out the top 10 of any one thing
and
when you look at the top multiples on
the market regardless brand you're
looking at 28 to 30 nutrients in there
maybe 13 minerals well what about the
other 47
on the average each mineral gives you
and deficiency will give you anywhere
from 10 to 25 diseases
calcium deficiency alone gives you 147
different diseases
then
when you look at
you go to a health store health food
store
or you go to a grocery or a pharmacy
they'll have vitamin a vitamin c calcium
magnesium zinc
and if you if you buy a 10
bottle of these nutrients and you have
to get
bottles to get each of your nutrients
you're looking at 720
for a month
okay so we've gotten it down to using
natural products and we test everything
to make sure each batch has all 90
central nutrients and optimal amounts
uh for for 120 pound person it's going
to cost them
um
something like two bucks a day
for a 200 pound person this could cost
you maybe five dollars a day and that's
going to support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissues muscles heart lungs
liver kidneys brain eyes
and
myself
this month using the chinese numbers
i've turned 75
and
i haven't been to a doctor with me being
the patient for 68 years been taking the
90 essential nutrients twice a day
for 68 years never been on prescription
medication
my
my blood pressure is
90 over 60. my pulse is 43 which is a
little high for me is normally 38 is my
pulse
and i can go to a pharmacy without a
prescription buy all the test strips
that a doctor will use in a physical in
his office for a buck 50 a test strip
and all my numbers right dead center of
normal i've been doing this for 68 years
and if everybody does this the medical
system will be real humble and so that's
my job is to teach people to use all 90
essential nutrients is very economical
150 a month instead of 750 you can't buy
individual nutrients and put them it's
too expensive
and the average person will say well
i'll leave this one i'll just take the
top ten and i hope i'll get the others
out of my food it's actually insane to
do that when a dog food has everything
in it
our baby's formulas for instance gary
have
um
uh something like 13 minerals
whereas the other 47 or and the food
chemistry journal came out in april of
uh 2000 2012 and said
baby farmless we're very familiar with i
mean very well respected baby farmers
have less than 20 percent of the
minerals and less than 20 percent of the
vitamins our babies need dog food has
100 laboratory rat food has 100 chicken
food has 100
and our kids have less than 20 percent
during the break we were talking briefly
uh about scurvy and uh tell us about the
history of that and how that was uh was
essentially cured
okay well scurvy of course is a very
famous very important historical disease
more than two million british and
japanese soldiers died
over a hundred year period from scurvy
because as they would go on these long
sea voyages they didn't have anything
fresh to eat they would eat salted pork
and
that sort of thing but they didn't have
cabbage they didn't have fresh fruit
green things to eat and so vitamin c
which when you're deficient in vitamin c
you get scurvy and
so they didn't have an adequate source
of vitamin c and after 90 days at sea
they're all coming down their teeth are
falling out their bones are falling
apart connective tissue is falling apart
they hemorrhage to death
and
it costs the british navy and the
japanese navy enormous sums of money
plus uh the lives of these sailors
and of course a lot of the how long did
it play how long did it plague these
navies
oh several hundred years okay and of
course the medical doctors at that time
were looking for the germ
you have some grandmother say well just
let each sailor take a head of cabbage
with them or a basket of fruit and it
won't happen
well where's the germ lady there's got
to be a germ because this is one of
those failed medical theories where they
thought they fought louis pasteur
for a hundred years right his theory of
the germ theory
um
because he's the one that came up with
the here's a little pasture he was a
wine chemist and he was only a wine
chemist and we doctors know that all
diseases are caused by
things like or four humors are out of
balance or spontaneous generation
there's no such things as germs
well von luinhock the guy that came up
with the microscope and pasture could
see these germs and he could take pus
from somebody or a sputum from somebody
that had pneumonia or dying and injected
into an animal and caused the same
disease and so he knew these little bugs
called germs you can see under the
microscope caused disease and he came up
with the germ theory and medical doctors
fought him even long after he died once
they believed in germs
and everything including every
nutritional disease you can think of
including scurvy and barry berry and
pellegra and so forth were all caused by
germs and millions of people died
because they kept looking for the germ
and disregarded what grandma said about
eating more fresh fruits and vegetables
now
there's a hot hot debate about
cancer and
its causes
in your research uh over time have you
discovered that cancer is also
of the cause of a vitamin deficiency
well there's many things we know about
cancer and number one
and
this is one of my lawsuits against the
fda and i prevailed in federal courts to
be able to say
that you can
prevent or reduce the risk of many
different cancers by supplementing with
200 micrograms a day of the trace
mineral selenium reduce the risk of
certain cancers like breast cancer by 82
percent prostate cancer by 69
and um breast cancer by 32 just by
supplementing with 200 micrograms of
selenium you can also reduce the risk of
breast cancer by 462 percent
by just cooking your meat medium rare
instead of well done
the
cancer bullseye in america is jackson
mississippi
now when you look at the cancer rate
across the united states the worst place
to be in america for cancer is jackson
mississippi why is that well
um that's because they fry everything
there there's rumors they even fry water
we know they fry ice cream but they not
even fry water
and
fried foods cause trans fatty acids
heterocyclic amines and acrylamides
these are chemicals far more dangerous
than anything that monsanto and dow
chemical will make and eating fried
foods causes cancer people have to come
to grips with this
and of course this goes along with the
study from the university of south
carolina which came out in 1998 let me
just jump in there real quick i love
fried foods is there do you have a
supplement that i can take that i can
still eat my fried foods i wouldn't
suggest that but
we do know that antioxidants
which will reduce
the level of free radical damage
you're going to have to eat
a hundred thousand or act points an hour
okay
to compensate for eating fried foods i
just wouldn't play with that it's like
playing with a loaded gun and pointing
at yourself and pulling trigger and say
well there's only one shell in there bam
you know you're dead the same thing is i
wouldn't give anybody permission to take
more antioxidants than eat fried foods i
just i don't do it
you're going to get some protection but
i've known people who have tried it and
they didn't do well and so i wouldn't
suggest it so what
makes your
product your vitamin supplements your 90
for life program what sets it apart
from from the pack you know are all
supplements created equal is the
question well the question's answer of
course is that no not all supplements
are created equal for instance
what makes me different you said it very
well at the beginning i have a degree in
agriculture i have a degree in
veterinary medicine but you left out the
fact that i do have also a postdoc in
compared pathology right to autopsies
and animals and people
and this is before i became a
naturopathic physician
and in one study i did over 20 000
autopsies at the center for the biology
of natural systems at washington
university at the st louis zoo and the
shaw's mechanical gardens in st louis in
the 60s and 70s
and the book that came out of that 1200
pages as in the smithsonian institute as
a national treasure the bottom line of
that study was that there's 454 species
of zoo animals 3 000 humans 17 thousands
of change of over 454 species of animals
10 million chemistries isn't a book that
thick
and
the bottom line of the study gary was
that every animal and every human being
that dies of what we would call natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
disease
if you ask a medical doctor to name all
the rare earths
which double the lifespans of laboratory
animals in double-blind randomized
studies
they can't name you one they don't know
what a rare earth is
these are substances
for our audiences benefit of what is a
rare earth okay well rare earth is a
trace trace trace mineral
uh you need say a thousand times less
of uterobn mutrium
neodymium procedure
than you do selenium or magnesium or
chromium or vanadium
and but they're essential for maximizing
your genetic potential for longevity and
health
okay it will double the lifespan of
laboratory animals and so why not be
aware of those and make sure you're
taking adequate amounts to make your
genes and your dna happy
okay
well
if a doctor doesn't even know they exist
because all he knows about is calcium
and magnesium and some potassium
and otherwise they're extremely ignorant
that's why only dead doctors don't lie
so what conditions give bodies the best
chance
to heal themselves so we don't have to
go
to the to the dead doctor and get get a
pharmaceutical
prescription
and which is comes along with multiple
side effects sure well first of all you
have to appreciate gary with the
exception of antibiotics which do cure
syphilis antibiotics will cure strep
throat
bacterial meningitis gangrene these
sorts of things
like with the exception of antibiotics
which is about 500 i'm in the
physician's desk reference there's not a
single pharmaceutical that's prescribed
by medical doctors that cure anything
they all relieve symptoms
there's no law requiring a doctor to
cure you when there's a cure available
for instance
rheumatoid arthritis is curable in two
weeks
but why would a doctor want to make 300
in office calls by curing you of your
rheumatoid arthritis in two or three
weeks when you can make 750 000 by
treating you for 25 years
insurance pays why worry about it
there are other philosophies so
rheumatoid arthritis is a major problem
in america a lot of people watching this
right now are suffering from yes um what
mineral supplements would you say
that individual could take to alleviate
some of that uh some of that
that problem that disease well
rheumatoid arthritis gary has is two
parts number one the actual disease is
different from bone bone arthritis or
osteoarthritis or osteopenia
osteoporosis which is simply a
nutritional deficiency
okay rheumatoid arthritis is a
combination
of a nutritional deficiency and an
infection with a bug called mycoplasma
and there's a tetracycline called
minocycline it's a member of the
tetracycline family and i can kill that
bug in two weeks with middle cycling i
can kill the mycoplasma in two weeks so
it kills the infection just like i can
kill the syphilis bacteria
with penicillin in two weeks
same concept no big deal but then you
have the damage that that bacteria did
to the joints joint capsule tendons and
ligaments and deficiencies
complicated things by causing all kinds
of deformities
well we have a program
we call the healthy bone and joint pack
which has all 90 essential nutrients
plus what we call the secret sauce for
supporting and promoting maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue
joint capsules discs between the
vertebrae all the things that are
damaged by this infection
and so
all the drugs that are sold on tv or the
doctor might prescribe for a fermented
arthritis gold shots methotrexate
and some of the pharmaceuticals which
i'm not going to name
only relieve symptoms
none of them kill the bug none real none
of them rebuild anything they relieve
pain and inflammation and so over time
the infection and the degenerative
disease gets worse and worse and worse
then you have joint replacements and
this is where the big expense comes in
780 thousand dollars for each hip that's
160 000 dollars for two hips and the
knee replacements and the finger
replacements and forward joints and the
in
the fingers and and the
back of the hand the wrist the elbow the
shoulders
and so it gets pretty scary but doctors
know that each
rheumatoid arthritis patient is money in
the bank they just draw on that deposit
anytime they need the money kids going
into harvard hey come on in frank i have
a brand new hip i'm going to try on you
i'm going to give you a discount on it
frank comes in charge the guy it's 78
000 insurance company
sounds like um
sounds like a
like a bit of a racket to me it is a
racket
what other industry
can kill engine infect 15 million other
customers their workplace every year and
still be in business year after year
after year
let's talk about exercise
and
just how important is exercise
compared to
vitamins
for
good general health
there is no comparison if you have a
choice of taking all 90 essential
nutrients and exercise take the 90
essential nutrients skip the exercise
exercise supplementation is a fatal
fatal fatal disease what you think about
it gary you take all the professional
sports combined
the average lifespan of professional
athletes is 62 football players is 51
there's never been a professional
athlete ever lived to be 100.
so what's so good about exercise in fact
in
december of 1982 the journal the
american medical association came out
with a little study that said while
running a man's risk of heart attack
death increases by 700 percent
so why would anybody want to run
okay if you're gonna run you better be
supplementing heavily and so we came up
with a sports drink that has a hundred
nutrients in it replacing everything
that's in your sweat most sports drinks
have either two
four or six nutrients in there ours has
a hundred
because sweat is not water so what is a
soup
of everything floating around your blood
so you have a sports drink as well yes
and how does that compare to the stuff
that we find in the gas station
refrigerator well
again
depending on the brand they might have
two nutrients you might have four
nutrients or six nutrients how do you
compare two four or six nutrients with a
hundred nutrients
and your sweats can attain any content
your sweat is going to contain anywhere
between
um
say 65
and 90 nutrients depending if you're
supplementing or not
if you just drink water to rehydrate
yourself you'll rehydrate yourself but
your knees will break down
because you're not getting enough
nutrients to replace what you're losing
through the sweat
uh you might get muscle cramps you're
gonna get muscle tears uh you're going
to get a sudden heart death like a lot
of 10 000 young athletes every year in
america die from a sudden heart death
this is due to a deficiency of a single
mineral selenium
ruptured aneurysms while running
cause the death of many young athletes
and this is caused by deficiencies they
have another single mineral copper
well there's no
with the exception of our spore shrink
there's no other sports drink that has
copper and selenium and they all have
just sodium and chloride
okay
now what about children um
you know we've seen the little gummies
that kids can have and and those types
of things how important uh is supplement
for a growing child
well a growing child needs more vitamins
minerals per pound of body weight than
an adult like you and me we're
maintaining ourselves right
and we just want to maximize our genetic
potential for longevity and health well
these kids not only are they looking at
that requirement but also they're
looking at growth and puberty and all
the other special pressures that are put
on their systems
and so per pound of body weight a
youngster needs far more nutrients each
day than we do for maintenance per pound
of body weight
so
um and again
in
april of 2012 and food chemistry journal
said that
our very well-respected baby foods baby
formulas uh contain less than 20 of the
minerals and vitamins that our babies
need so we have an insane system
in fact to cover story
time magazine in december of 2008 came
out and said that our children are not
going to live as long as us or
our kids are the first generation
they're not going to live as long as the
parents apparent many parents will be
burying their children because they're
not getting the nutrition that we got
simply because there's no more wood
ashes going into the garden we've dammed
up the river there's no more silt coming
into the floods every year and then
here's the doctor and his white coat
saying now don't you supplement gary
it's bad for you you can overdose you
know
well doc we're coming up to the end of
the end of the the clock here and uh i
want to ask you one last question yes
sir what do you think
are the leading causes
of the health care crisis uh in the
united states
well the main cause is the medical
system has been
made into a
a monopoly this monopoly
is
self-pleasing
they have been able to render all their
competition as quacks
insurance only pays them
and any industry that can kill injury
and infect 15 million customers or
workplace every year and still be in
business next year or next month or next
week is an amazing industry when you
think about it
they also infect 2 million people each
year in hospitals alone of which 90 000
die
what if iran or north korea would send
over a biological weapon an
intercontinental ballistic missile
and kill 90 000 people and infect 2
million in a large population center we
declare war on them here's one trade
that does it every year in the workplace
nobody seems to care
that's the biggest problem they don't
have any competition if you're going to
put a roof on your house gary or put a
sprinkler system yard you're going to
get five bids
you're going to find out from something
like better business bureau or one of
these things online
who's the best one
and you're going to
find if there's any complaints about
them
people go to the same doctor for 25 30
40 years whatever the doctor says they
do without even checking with another
doctor
those that's the main problem
if there's one thing you want our
audience to take away from today from
this interview and we've covered so much
ground here and i wish we had more time
because we could keep on going i know we
could um but if there's one thing you
really want our audience to take away
from today what would that be
that they must supplement with the 90
essential nutrients
and
do it obsessively i've done it for twice
a day for 68 years been blessed with
perfect health
if everybody were like me health-wise
guess what gary the medical system would
be really really unhappy
and what do you think would happen with
obamacare
oh
well
um obamacare is problematic
simply because
it failed thinking that the reason why
america is sick is because they didn't
have access to
doctors obamacare is like putting people
in the furnace
so
having the supplements would
prevent that from happening because
you put six quarts oil in your car to
prevent the engine from running up do
you put the six quarts of oil in your
car after the engine burns up but before
the engine burns up
so you take the 90 centimetres before
you get sick you just don't get sick